welcome back everybody recently i posted
a survey on my social media
to real tractor owners what is your
favorite tractor attachment that you
have we got a lot of feedback a lot of
results we compiled everything and made
a top 10 list we're going to share that
with you now now we asked this survey in
the summertime and
funny enough there wasn't much snow
equipment mentioned on there so
depending when you're watching this
video maybe snow equipment is a bigger
deal at that point in the year and let's
have some fun how many of the top 10
tractor attachments do you own yourself
leave a comment down below or you have
one that didn't make the list make a
case for it as well we are proud to be
sponsored by borah wheel spacers if
you're looking for a stability solution
for your machine check out borah link
down below hey and if you'd be so kind
i'd love to get a thumbs up from you hit
that subscribe button down below to see
more and if you want something for your
tractor yeah we have a few attachments
check out
[Music]
goodworkstractors.com we're going to go
in reverse order from number 10 all the
way to number one
it was overwhelming not even close
number one you'll want to stick around
for that but number 10
is a tiller folks are looking for
attachments that are life-changing i
think and a tiller is something you
cannot replicate by doing by hand and
the ability
to turn
unfinished ground into prepped ground
for seeding whether that's for food
plots or for
a garden maybe you're even doing
driveway prep we did that recently as
well it makes a huge difference in
something many of you can't live without
on our website you'll find tillers by
rhino by tar river and by dirt dog so
check it out for more information
[Music]
next up on the list i was a little
surprised about this one not that i
don't appreciate it because i enjoy it
myself but i wouldn't have said it was
my favorite the hydraulic top link i
didn't see a hydraulic side length like
a top and a tilt kit that wasn't
mentioned at all but just the top link
which for me is very handy for a couple
of reasons the ability to hook up to any
attachment or to be able to quickly
switch between different attachments
that are maybe sitting at a bit of a
different angle is going to be very
helpful additionally when you're using
those attachments on your three-point
hitch maybe ground engaging
things like a box blade or a lamp plane
or maybe it's a tiller or maybe even a
rotary cutter you can quickly and easily
from the operator seat change that angle
the only downside of having a hydraulic
top link in my opinion is the fact that
it does require an additional hydraulic
outlet on the back of the tractor in
order to operate
[Music]
i'm proud of you guys for choosing this
one those of you that did but a ballast
box or a ballast solution was next on
the list now this isn't something that
you actually do any work with however it
is going to allow you to do more work
with your front end loader or maybe if
you have ballast on the front of your
tractor
you can use a tiller or a brush hog
easier if you don't have a loader but
it's going to let you do work more
safely and more confidently knowing that
you are properly planted on the ground
now many tractor manuals i'll take the
1025r for example it's a small tractor a
sub compact the manual is going to tell
you to use a thousand pounds or actually
a thousand and fifty pounds minimum of
ballast weight when you're using the
front end loader now that is a lot of
weight and if you have a larger tractor
that number is going to keep on climbing
typically you need a lot of different
types of ballast weight to achieve that
minimum with a ballast box it's going to
be one of the cheaper solutions get some
wheel weights maybe liquid ballast
inside your tires i've done some videos
all about ballast weight but i'm glad to
see it on the list
[Music]
i didn't have to walk very far for this
next one it's sitting right next to our
ballast box it is going to be the
backhoe that's what you guys chose for
the next attachment on your list now
remember this survey was done and these
results are compiled of real tractor
owners folks like you at home we all
know i wouldn't be choosing tobacco to
be on this list now i do think a backhoe
is useful for many different
applications and projects that come up
that's not why i wouldn't put it on this
list it's more of a
a return on your investment for a lot of
folks they're going to have
this big old very expensive attachment
besides the tractor it's probably the
most expensive part of their purchase
that they would make they have a project
or two not everybody but just a lot of
folks they use it they take it off it
sits there and it's gonna just kind of
sit out in the sun or fade away and it
ends up being thousands and thousands of
dollars that is just sitting there not
getting used when perhaps you could just
rent out a mini excavator for two or
three weekends get your projects done
and you don't have all that money tied
up
[Music]
so the word bucket showed up a whole lot
in the survey results and so i took the
liberty of combining the stump bucket
the regular bucket just buckets in
general and lump them together and it's
hard to argue with folks because buckets
are so so handy when you need them for
moving large quantities of material for
digging out stumps for maybe planting
trees moving rocks all sorts of
different applications
it's easy to see why a standard tractor
bucket is going to come with pretty much
every compact tractor on the market
these days and while the stump bucket
like this one right here is one of the
top attachments i sell at good works
tractors
[Music]
now i do want to give a shout out to an
honorable mention the quick hitch was
listed quite a few times didn't quite
make the cut but it was right on the
cusp so a quick hitch really isn't a
tractor attachment it's more of an
accessory that's going to make hooking
up to three-point attachments that much
easier you simply back up to an
attachment maybe you have to lengthen or
shorten your top link but it's going to
make that connection process that much
easier which can be a major pain to deal
with especially for larger heavier
attachments the special thing about the
category 1 spiko quick hitch is that it
does not require bushings the land
prides of the world the john deere eye
match the harbor freights all require
you to put bushings on every three-point
attachment you have these are sized to
be a direct fit to category one pins we
sell these we ship them all over the
country all the time
[Music]
this next one kind of validates why i
don't ever buy tractors without front
end loaders because so many of you
responded and said a front end loader
itself is the most valuable tractor
attachment so i buy and sell used
tractors along with all the new
attachments that i sell and whether it's
kubota or john deere you're going to see
a front end loader on every single one
out of the hundreds and hundreds maybe
thousands of tractors that i sold over
the years i can think of two instances
where somebody did not want the front
end loader on there that's how much of
almost a standard it should be although
when you're shopping for a new tractor
it is typically going to be priced
separately so make sure that's included
in your quote but i think where folks
are going with a front-end loader is the
fact that you can put a bucket on there
you can put a set of pallet forks a snow
pusher a grapple a bale sphere the list
goes on and on and on with the different
things you can do as long as you have a
quick attached system like a skid steer
quick attach or a john deere quick
attach
[Music]
next up on the list we're talking about
mowers
including a couple different kinds a
brush hog a slasher a shredder
a cutter a bush hog
you hear it called a lot of things and
then also flail mowers all right so
we're not talking about finish mowers
not your belly mower or not even a
three-point finish mower but these are
for cutting your fields maintaining that
long stuff before it gets too out of
control and if there ever was an item i
think that's on this list because of the
time of year that the survey was done i
definitely think it would be a cutter it
is hard to think about living without
one of those right now
[Music]
next up grapples and you know what we're
getting pretty high what are we number
three now on the list and it's easy to
see why you know you can just grab and
pick whatever you want to with the front
end loader that's why the front end
loader made the list because these are
one of the handiest attachments now we
carry all sorts of grapples here
one of the downsides of many grapples is
you have to have a third function on
them so if you use any traditional
hydraulic grapple you got to have
you know you have two functions on your
tractor right to raise and lower your
front end loader and to curl and roll
the bucket that's two functions in order
to open and close the jaws of the
grapple you got to have a third function
on there so if you don't have those
hydraulics on your tractor there's three
options that we can help with so number
one is going to be the brush crusher
it's a completely mechanical system
there's no extra hydraulics no extra
electric that's required you hook it up
to your front end loader and away you go
the next option for sub compacts and
small compact tractors is going to be a
work saver electric mini grapple it's
essentially a self-contained system it
includes and comes with the harness
everything you need to get up and
running you can have it installed in
about an hour and get to work the last
option if you do want to go with a
traditional hydraulic grapple is that we
have done videos about how you can
install a summit diverter kit so you use
your tractor's existing hydraulics
divert that flow you get a thumb switch
that way you can open and close the
grapple jaws it's going to be a diy
solution you can save five percent using
code gwt your order at summit hydraulics
link down below
[Music]
okay number two on the list is gonna be
i'm summing it up graders box blades
land planes it was something to level
out move material maintain resurface
that kind of thing with your three-point
hitch on your tractor so one of the main
purposes that comes to mind is going to
be resurfacing a gravel driveway maybe
you have washouts maybe it just hasn't
been maintained in a long time you can
get yourself a land plane or a box blade
and quickly and easily resurface that
and smooth out the ruts now with a tool
like a box blade we have a couple of
them here this is a rollover box blade
which i've never used and then we have a
traditional box blade those are going to
be also able to resurface driveways
they're going to be able to trap and
hold more material so if you want to
move maybe your
landscaping and want to kind of change
the contour of the ground you can scoop
up or almost drag a larger quantity of
material and move it from point a to
point b with a box blade and we're going
to go ahead and roll these pulverizers
into that same category a new tool for
me something i've never used i'm going
to have an opportunity to do so out of
the property but this is going to be
great for resurfacing and leveling
smoothing out rough areas especially on
drives
[Music]
finally we've reached number one the top
of the mountain
so suspenseful i know
number one is going to be pallet forks
which it's hard to argue this was
far and away the number one response and
number one with good reason the uses for
pallet forks are just numerous and
lifting actual pallets is probably just
the tip of the iceberg and something
that most of you maybe never use them
for but many of you have responded and
said those pallet forks stay on your
tractor more often than a bucket does or
any other attachment because you can
pick up and move anything under the sun
that you can think of out of your truck
bed maybe moving attachments around
maybe picking up logs out of the woods a
poor man's grapple anytime you don't
feel like bending over and breaking your
back is a good time to use pallet forks
we've done it we've made it through the
list how many attachments on this list
do you own right now is there something
else that should be on the list maybe
depending on the time of year maybe it's
fall i can see a bagger being a pretty
important item maybe it's winter time
you have your snow blower your snow push
or your snow plow whatever it is join
the conversation by leaving a comment
down below if you want to participate in
the next survey that i send out make
sure you subscribe to my youtube channel
or like the facebook page as well i'm
going to post those survey requests on
there with a question of the week we'd
love to have you participate if you
enjoyed the video hit that like button
down below and if you want something for
your tractor all that stuff we talked
about today visit goodworkstractors.com
thanks again for stopping by and until
next time stay safe we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you